What? Non-binary language will
be banned in part of Germany?
Since when do you
read physical newspapers?
It’s retro, you know
So, what’s happened?
Germany's largest state
has banned the use of
non-binary language in schools,
high schools and
public administration
You mean Mallorca?
No, Bavaria
It’s where they wear those
leather pants for Oktoberfest
It’s a very Catholic
and conservative state
It’s funny because
that outfit is so gay
What is gender-neutral language
like in German?
There are different variations,
but people often use an asterisk,
a colon or an underscore
to combine the masculine
and feminine form
and by that include
both women and non-binary people
And why do they
want to ban that?
Bavaria’s government says
“language has to be
clear and understandable”
Surely there are
bigger problems in the world?
You might want to know that
the use of
gender-neutral language in schools
and official communications
has become a big debate
in other countries as well,
including France and Argentina,
with advocates saying
that language has always adapted
to social and technical changes,
and critics saying it
threatens clarity and tradition
Right, sometimes I do miss
people speaking medieval Spanish…